wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
entschuldigen sie welche linie hält am
krankenhaus die 66 die hält am
krankenhaus sind sie krank soll ich
lieber ein taxi rufen
vielen dank aber ich habe dort meinen
ausweis vergessen
ärgerlich die 64 die hält auch am
krankenhaus die 64 fährt in die andere
richtung zum flughafen das hilft nicht
weiter
ok und reicht da ein normaler fahrschein
wissen sie das zum krankenhaus brauchen
sie ein ticket für drei euro 80
moment ich helfe ihnen ach es gibt noch
eine schnellere verbindung mit der 16
die strecke ist kürzer aber sie müssen
einmal umsteigen wie lange dauert die
fahrt ohne umsteigen
15 minuten länger dann ohne umsteigen
bitteschön
vielen dank
ich wünsche ihnen noch einen schönen
abend bitteschön in auch
[Musik]